[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio y las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo nueva york es
el lugar donde nació el molino
informativo un medio de comunicación que
cuenta historias de emigrantes y que
además está hecho por migrantes este
grupo está conformado por personas de
distintas nacionalidades que aunque no
son periodistas han aprendido a moverse
por la ciudad para recoger historias de
sus luchas y sus tradiciones y contarse
las al mundo hablamos con dos de sus
integrantes empezamos
en las comunidades mexicanas
principalmente en las zonas rurales el
molino es el lugar donde las personas
acuden a moler distintos ingredientes
que hacen parte de sus comidas
tradicionales este espacio termina
siendo un punto de encuentro donde las
personas conversan con vecinos y amigos
por ejemplo y se enteran de los últimos
acontecimientos de sus comunidades es
por eso que el molino es el nombre que
un grupo de emigrantes en nueva york'
que escogió para bautizar un portal
informativo en el que cuentan historias
de emigrantes este proyecto nació
durante la pandemia ante la necesidad de
dar a conocer sus situaciones así lo
explicó a france 24 beto paredes
coordinador editorial de el molino
informativo
y las comunidades migrantes mexicanas
sobre todo los pueblos originarios
residentes en nueva york
vieron que no
noten sus historias sus historias de
vida y sus historias frente a la
pandemia no estaban incluidas en las
barra tibás de los medios de
comunicación costaba mucho trabajo que
algunas de sus necesidades o
planteamientos
quedaran en algún medio de comunicación
y entonces se fue gestando la idea de
construir nuestro propio medio lo que
más llama la atención de este proyecto
es que quienes documentan estas
historias no son periodistas de
profesión son ciudadanos procedentes de
varios países que vieron la necesidad de
mostrar lo que pasa en su entorno
trabajan de manera voluntaria en el
molino informativo y para ello han
recibido formación de periodistas
profesionales así nos lo cuenta beto
paredes
y finalmente este año a inicios de este
año comenzamos una capacitación con un
grupo de alrededor de 20 personas que
son no son periodistas de oficio son
gente que trabaja diversos sectores y
que está interesada en destinar tiempo
para ejercer labores de comunicación
entonces decimos un poco la capacitación
en fotografía vídeo vamos trabajando
mucho lo de la escritura es
más rápido entonces hemos llamado a
diferentes periodistas y realidades que
de alguna manera se han solidarizado con
este proceso y de esta manera el molino
informativo se ha constituido como un
medio muy importante o muy querido por
este sector de la población en eeuu que
es fundamentalmente invisibilizado uno
de los integrantes de este proyecto es
esteban estévez un mexicano que llegó a
nueva york en los años 90 nacido en una
familia de agricultores en el estado de
puebla dice que al igual que lo han
hecho varios de su comunidad se vio
obligado a salir de su país por las
dificultades económicas que atravesaba
esteban se gana la vida haciendo
tapicería y alterna su trabajo haciendo
reportería para el molino allí
interpreta a crispín el inmigrante un
personaje que recorre la ciudad de nueva
york- entrevistando a personas migrantes
para conocer sus historias de vida lo
más difícil del proceso según dijo es
balancear el tiempo entre el molino y su
trabajo en una ciudad tan grande y
congestionada como la capital del mundo
esto dijo france 24
siempre he pensado que crispín después
este pues todos somos crispín en los que
estamos aquí en este país ya que todos
somos
migrantes y es de
pues cada uno de nosotros que estamos
laborando en los restaurantes hacia el
model y beris en los supermercados pues
estos son los crespines que estamos aquí
en nueva york y en esta ciudad y pues es
lo que trato de mostrar de qué es la
situación que uno vive aquí y como uno
se gana el el el trabajo el dinero de
mantener la familia y pagar la renta y
los gastos que conlleva vivir en una
ciudad tan grande y tan caros pues aquí
seguimos luchando y soñando que
crispín algún día
va a regresar
el molino informativo todavía es muy
nuevo pero genera todo tipo de
contenidos denuncia sus problemáticas
hay artículos analíticos y de opinión y
su meta en seguir creciendo por eso
buscan apoyo con este proyecto para
seguir formándose y consolidando sus
canales además de poder generar sus
propios ingresos para financiar sus
productos periodísticos pero más que
informar este portal tiene un objetivo
particular nos interesaría tener una red
de periodistas de reporteros de
reporteras y sin importar su geografía
pueden construir este proceso de
vinculación y que recuperen lazos
también con sus comunidades de origen
porque también hay una falta de
relacionamiento a veces por ejemplo si
alguien de méjico migras eeuu pierde el
contacto con su comunidad pierde
contacto con su familia y es importante
regresar es el contacto a través de una
plataforma que permita conocer ambas
realidades y también conocer otras
realidades que estén en américa latina
usted es un poco la intención que el
molino se convierte en un espacio de
organización
a largo plazo de manera comunitaria y
que en algún momento también sean
distintas lenguas que no solamente están
en español sino que más comunidades
puedan sentirse con la confianza de
obtener contenidos en sus propias
lenguas
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www france24
puntocom
[Música]